les marins pêcheurs a été très clair
depuis le début c'est à dire d'avoir des
réponses sur les impacts aujourd'hui on
n'y est pas on n'a pas assez réponse
[Musique]
ce
on est sur une zone où il ya beaucoup
d'activités de pêche on parle de 2 140
navires 600 à 700 marins pour une grosse
activité à terre aussi aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation où les enjeux
pêche ne sont pas forcément intégré dans
l'est dans les discussions ou papa dit
pas du tout en fait au goût des de la
profession qui sans pu acteurs de ce
projet c'est pour ça qu'ils en ont
demandé l'annulation
[Musique]
le forage en fait créer du bruit et
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas qu'elle peut
quelles sont les réponses en fait à
cette perturbation physique quelles sont
les réponses biologiques que peut avoir
les espèces certaines espèces certaines
populations d'oiseaux peuvent à terme
éviter cette zone d'implantation et plus
globalement la médecin arrive donc avec
un risque accru de soi de collisions
soin de ne pas pouvoir s'alimenter comme
ils le peuvent sur leur sur leur trajet
migratoire
[Musique]
dans l'hypothèse où ce projet devrait
réellement avoir lieu nous sommes trois
élus avec le maire d'erquy et le maire
de plévenon à avoir écrit au ministre de
l'économie et des finances ainsi qu'à la
ministre de l'environnement pour prévoir
un fonds de garantie l'idée serait que
pendant toute la durée de l'exploitation
l'exploitant soit contraint de mettre
des fonds sous séquestre afin qu'à
l'issue de l'exploitation on est un
fonds de garantie qui permettent la
remise en état des fonds marins
[Musique]